[Musique]
il
merci d'être fidèle avait y paie
émission dédiée aux personnalités
connues méconnues du département
également invité aujourd'hui christophe
bertrand bonjour bonjour et bienvenue
sur ce plateau maître artisan
chocolatier
vous êtes propriétaire de six boutiques
en région parisienne trois sont situés
dans le département des yvelines
rambouillet le mesnil saint denis et
puis versailles va également leur nom à
la reine astrid en août qui vous oblige
à l'excellence
on va revenir sur cette histoire il
s'agit de rendre hommage à l'épousé du
roi des belges c'est bien ça avoue se
marie en 1935 absolument ce qui est
compliqué avec le chocolat français
d'ailleurs oui avec on a une petite
guéguerre à savoir lequel est le
meilleur entre les belges et français
nous raconter un petit peu cette
histoire en quelques mots et comment
vous êtes arrivé sur cet établissement
parce que vous ne l'avez pas fondée en
1935 pour éclaircir le préciser oui
c'est en fait c'est une marque c'est une
à l'origine c'était une française qui
est descendue lille pour aller monter
une chocolaterie à paris et qui était
fan de la reine astrid et à l'époque où
celle ci est décédée elle avait demandé
à l'oreille la royauté belle chez
pouvait donner son nom à sa petite
marque ce qui lui a été accordée sous
réserve qu'elles fassent toujours des
produits d'excellence c'est comme ça
qu'est née cette marque qui ensuite a
grandi a été un moment au japon a été au
printemps haussmann également et donc
été sur paris et moi je les reprises en
2010 pour la faire grandir et donc à
l'époque l'export c'était plus ou moins
arrêtés je suis reparti un petit peu sur
le maroc
un peu de rabbi saoudite et puis et puis
voilà on fait 30 de femmes qui ont géré
auparavant la boutique ensuite vous vous
êtes arrivé vous avez repris le flambeau
et puis vous avez renforcer aussi cette
implantation en région parisienne il ya
des boutiques à versailles au mesnil
saint denis c'est assez récent en fait
oui c'est effectivement c'est un
confrère avec lequel on était assez à
ses copains qui s'appelle frank lobos et
qui est parti en retraite un peu
rapidement qui m'a proposé ses boutiques
il en avait trois j'en ai repris 2 sur 3
puisque en fait j'avais pour soi de
disparaître un peu de la capitale et
versailles est une adresse qui convient
très bien notamment y compris pour
l'exportation puisque quand même c'est
connu le versailles
voilà le nom de versailles fonctionne
très bien à l'étranger donc versailles
va devenir mon flagship et la boutique
du ministre ni j'habite pas très très
loin et donc pour moi c'était quand même
relativement facile de demander occupez
vous êtes l'un des rares chocolatiers de
france vous fait votre chocolat vous
n'êtes pas confiseurs expliquer la
différence bravo tout à fait dans les
technologies du terme effectivement un
confiseur achète du chocolat elle
transforme et un chocolatier est censé
acheter les fèves de cacao et en faire
du chocolat en passant par la
torréfaction et c'est alors ça veut pas
dire que ça va être meilleur je vais pas
dire que
le fait de faire son chocolat fait qu'on
fait quelque chose de meilleur c'est une
démarche qui est différente
c'est une démarche de passion c'est un
peu comme les brasseurs de bière il y en
avait pas tant que ça ya quelques années
les petites brasseries artisanales et
puis ça pullule on revient sur ces
phénomènes là et pour moi c'est surtout
si l'idée de s'affranchir de l'industrie
qui nous vend du chocolat racontant
certainement quelques belles histoires
moi j'ai envie que mon histoire elle
soit la mienne et que je sache
pertinemment ce que je fais et surtout
de savoir notamment comme enjeu
rémunèrent les producteurs de ne pas
avoir le même chocolat que vous langer
voisin parce qu'à la fin si on achète
tout cela dans des choses vraies
différences et puis aussi d'être maîtres
de la chaîne de a à z
et d'ailleurs on va rapidement et venir
et puis on va en voir des images est
également mais vous fait ses choix
éthique vous êtes parti au cameroun est
également voilà on voit quelques images
on verra la vidéo aussi dans un instant
le départ au cameroun la petite histoire
c'est une femme qu'on voit en haut de
l'écran là qui s'appelle aristide qui
habite au cameroun qui est productrice
de cacao dans un petit village où y'a
pas douillet pas d'électricité et qui
cherchait à essayer d'exporter son cacao
est donc en cherchant sur internet elle
a trouvé une liste sur laquelle il y
avait les 15 meilleurs chocolatiers
français il se trouve que j'étais dedans
elle s'est dit les premiers devraient un
peu occupé je prends les appeler à
l'esprit du milieu tient assez astrid la
reine aristide
ça marche bien et donc elle m'a contacté
comme ça alors je lui ai dit bon je vais
pas prendre le risque de vous envoyer de
l'argent avant de voir du cacao je suis
pas trop idiot quand même mais si vous
prenez ce risque là je vous promets je
vous de payer cette femme donc a pris un
risque qui est énorme pour elle
puisqu'elle a emprunté 700 euros et les
frais de transport nous laissant qui lui
est faite de cacao ce qui correspond à
un an de son salaire
donc je me suis senti un peu redevable
du fait que moi je n'avais pas fait
confiance et elle m'avait totalement
fait confiance et je me suis dit allez
on va faire mon prochain voyage et au
cameroun et à l'époque je voulais et
c'est d'investir un peu dans le cacao
culture je ne parle pas l'espagnol je
voulais faire un peu d'amérique centrale
j'avais commencé à prendre des cours
et là d'un seul coup voilà c'est un pays
francophone s'est il n'y a pas de
décalage horaire
les billets d'avion sont pas chères et
il y avait tout à faire chez eux et donc
c'est comme ça qu'est née l'idée de les
aider à monter une coopérative puisqu'en
fait le sujet essentiel pour le chocolat
que les gens connaissent pas trop
cétoine de la fermentation
si le chocolat pour avoir du goût doit
subir une fermentation d'un pays
producteur dans les six heures qui
suivent sa récolte on doit mettre les
fèves de cacao dans un grand bac en bois
et les laisser pendant six jours pour
faire un simple la fermentation va
développer les précurseurs d'arômes du
cacao c'est un peu comme du roquefort si
vous mettez pas des champignons bleu et
du mycélium vous allez manger une sorte
de fromage à pâte molle prend pas trop
de boue 90% du cac 1 mondial n'est pas
fermenté donc il ne se valorisent pas en
goût et donc il ne se valorisent pas
financièrement c'est à dire que ça vaut
rien et malheureusement les cours du
cacao mondial sont au plus bas et donc
si on les aide à faire la fermentation
d'un seul coup au lieu d' intéresser
l'industrie
on va intéresser les chocolatiers
confiseurs et on va vendre du chocolat
qui s'appelle cameroun et je pense que
je suis le premier ou des premiers en
france à proposer du chocolat du
cameroun c'est le cinquième pays
producteur mondial
mais en fait vous ne mangez jamais parce
que peut-être il enrobe les cacahuètes
ou peut-être qu'il est au tour des
barres céréales que vous acheter au
supermarché on ne sait pas où il est les
avaient aidés de a à z accompagne et
vous l'avez expliqué également comment
valoriser ce qu'ils récoltaient puisque
les méthodes
lorsque vous avez découvert cette
exploitation était assez rudimentaire en
fait c'était à même le sol alors qu'il
ne faut pas que ce soit surélevé
voilà exactement le cacao dans 90% des
cas il est séché à même le sol donc
c'est pas terrible en termes de ses
charges
ça donne des fèves de cacao qui sont peu
noirci un peu moisie alors qu'il faut
simplement les sécher sur des claies en
hauteur qui sont restés en bambou et là
l'idée c'était surtout de provoquer la
fermentation d'organiser une coopérative
qui dit tous les mardis tous les jeudis
vous ramenez vos fèves de cacao on
aimait tout ensemble dans un grand bac
en bois et la fermentation peut démarrer
si vous ne vous organisez pas en
coopérative ya pas de fermentation n'ya
pas de développement de précurseurs
d'arômes de cacao donc on a fait tout ça
on a fait ce petit bâtiment qu'on voit
en bois avec des bacs de fermentation et
puis les clés de séchage etc
et puis bon il se trouve que l'appui ce
qui est alors la voix la voix la photo
aussi ce n'est pas le bâtiment pour la
fermentation celui ci est ce bâtiment là
puisque cette coopération est même allé
au-delà vous mêmes rénover une école
voilà ça fait partie des petites choses
qui toutes ces choses là en deux ans et
demi je pensais pas au début je m'étais
dit et je les aide juste à faire une
coopérative et puis voilà ça se passe
comme ça on me tend la main puis on vous
prend le bras etc
et puis cette école était en ruines
il y avait une partie de la toiture qui
était ouverte donc il y avait deux
salles de classe qui pouvait pas servir
on voit qu'il ya des parpaings là parce
que les murs étaient totalement versé
très aéré un formidable mais bon très
pratique
et puis on a eu cette idée l'année
dernière avec mes enfants et une dizaine
de jeunes de mon village là dans la
vallée de chevreuse et on est parti à
dix pendant quinze jours on a
entièrement tout démonter tout refait et
c'est un petit budget de 20 millions
euros je crois qu'on a réuni ce qui fait
que à l'échelle du petit artisan que je
suis j'ai l'impression d'en faire autant
parfois que des industriels qui vous
racontent sur leurs catalogues qu'ils
ont aussi rénover une école mais ils
font 600 millions d'euros de chiffre ça
a été une véritable découverte pour nous
où vous aviez toujours cet engagement
cette solidarité cette fibre solidaire
moi j'ai des parents j'ai grandi en
afghanistan thaïlande
en algérie et les parents qui étaient à
l'unesco ma mère était très investi
amnesty international donc forcément
quelque chose qui fait qu'on est touché
par ce type de démarche
et puis voilà ça c'est fait c'est
formidable c'est avec avec les enfants
c'était une histoire géniale parce que
c'était pas seulement les 15 jours sur
place qui étaient géniaux s'était monté
le projet avant se réunit ensemble que
les mômes se rendent compte que bénévole
c'est compliqué il y en a il y en a
quelques-uns qui foutent rien et les
autres travaillent en fait ça les agace
et puis finalement on essaie de leur
expliquer c'est ça le bénévolat il y en
a qui ne font rien mais ils sont là cd
on peut rien leur dire
et puis peut-être que le jour on va être
parti au cameroun ils vont être les plus
actifs de la borne voilà donc et c'est
est je pense un enrichissement pour eux
ces parcours de vie qui enrichissent les
plus jeunes on va sans doute voir les
images aussi de ces jeunes qui vous ont
accompagnés on va revenir sur sur la
région ile de france cette fois ci parce
que vous ne travaillez pas qu'avec les
produits du cameroun vous avez aussi
cette volonté est de faire des produits
locaux l'ile-de-france pour la literie
pour la laiterie par nos tombes réalité
exacte sur pas mal de choses je pense
qu'il ya un moment où on est
effectivement mais c'est je pense un
phénomène de mode si c'est aussi de la
raison mais faut revenir à des principes
de bages et un apiculteur nos villages
donc forcément le miel de châtaignier
qui accompagne la ganache il est pris
dans mon village je vais pas aller
chercher ailleurs
j'achète mon lait pour les ganaches à la
laiterie de corbeil la crème fleurette
qui est la dernière lettre i d'île de
france et qui prend son ensemble est à
saint rémy les chevreuse et fontaines
d'eau qui le paye 35 centimes au litre
cette démarche à nos coups de pas
grand-chose à faire juste de décider de
faire un tout petit peu plus d'attention
dans mes achats et particulièrement pour
le chocolat je n'achète que du cacao qui
est équitable et bio ou alors en circuit
court pour le cameroun il est pas tout à
fait bio mais pas loin quand même parce
que la réalité c'est qu'on n'a pas trop
les moyens de mettre des insecticides
donc on n'en met pas beaucoup et à côté
de ça je ne veux pas acheter du sucre
équitable et bio parce qu'ils font et
qui viennent de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique je trouve ça
pas raisonnable et donc je préfère
acheter du sucre à soupe dans 77
puisqu'on fait du sud de betteraves dans
la région parisienne et qui n'ont pas de
raison d'aller l'acheter à l'autre bout
du monde
donc je ne ferai jamais du chocolat
équitable et bio juste parce que mon
sucre il est il est locale ce qui vous
permet tout de même de proposer c'est
vous qui me l'avait dit une tarte au
chocolat 100% engagé c'est peut-être la
seule
oui je pense oui parce que effectivement
je veux on fait une tarte au chocolat la
plupart de mes confrères qui font du
chocolat on a une cinquantaine en france
sont pas pâtissier en général y font que
du chocolat et on est peut-être trois en
france ou quatre affaires à la fois de
la chute de la chocolaterie et la
pâtisserie et donc j'ai un nouveau chef
s'appelle mathieu super tiki et qui est
extra qui m'a rejoint ya deux mois et
qui donc nous fait une tarte chocolat
qui est ce candidat avec une ou des
teams de grues et sur le dessus à partir
du chocolat du cameroun dont on peut
dire que quasiment il est fait de a à z
par mois puisque il existe notamment
grâce à l'impulsion j'ai donné dans le
village
et puis je vais même aller un peu plus
loin puisque l'été dernier j'ai planté
un hectare et demi je voudrais essayer
de d'avancé sur le bio est donc mais pas
du but en mettant des insecticides bio
mais du vrai bio sur des modèles
d'agroforesterie donc j'ai une jeune
fille qui est ingénieur agronome qui m'a
demandé un stage parce qu'elle avait lu
un petit peu ce que je faisais et qui
part de moi au cas monde cet été on va
essayé d'implanter ce qu'on appelle des
arbres fertile iter entre les cacaoyers
ce sont des arbres qui attrapent la zot
dans l'air qui leur distribue dans les
racines donc sur le principe il faut le
vérifier on va enrichir le sol en azote
naturellement donc les cacaoyers vont
donner 25 % de cacao en plus et
logiquement vous pourriez accepté de ne
plus mettre d'insecticides et perdre 25%
doha de votre récolte et vous êtes
équilibré on va faire également du
compost n'en font jamais et on va aussi
s'est planté entre les cacaoyers et les
arbres fertile iter des des arbres
fruitiers et les avocatiers de façon à
ce que les cacaoculteurs n'est pas des
revenus uniquement entre septembre et
décembre moment et récolte du cacao mais
également au mois de mars avril parce
que comme ça ça leur permet de lisser
leurs activités
donc toutes les bonnes raisons de vous
rendre à la reine astrid dans l'un des
six établissements en ile de france 10
est roi dans les yvelines vous ferez
vous ferez du bien parce que c'est bon
si tu n'aimes pas l'oublier il faut que
ce soit et marchent décryptable des
démarches environnementales et puis
démarche gustatives aussi un cc c'est
aussi le but est juste pour conclure
expliquez nous pourquoi vous n'êtes pas
ce qu'on a entendu tout votre parcours
vos engagements pourquoi vous êtes
tourné vers cette profession finalement
c'est le hasard j'ai fait un billet
acheté en 2003 et puis j'ai bossé sur
une chocolaterie dans le cadre des
études qui m'a envoyé à la maison du
chocolat où j ai travaillé pendant
pendant sept huit ans et j'ai adoré ce
produit parce qu'en fait on peut on peut
créer dans le chocolat sans faire des
investissements incroyable on fait des
choses très simples j'étais lundi j'ai
racheté une petite charcuterie dans un
petit village au sud de chartres pour
pouvoir stocker mon cacao et il y avait
un fumoir évidemment donc je ne pouvais
pas m'empêcher d'essayer fumée du cacao
avec du bois de hêtre et je vais faire
des essais du foie aussi ça coûte quoi
de faire des essais rien du tout passé
alors que dans l'industrie c'est un peu
plus compliqué je trouve ça génial dans
le chocolat de pouvoir s'amuser avec
assez peu de choses merci beaucoup
christopher horner s'est mémoriser
maître artisan un chocolatier à la reine
astrid et à bientôt sur terry 78
[Musique]